jeans in portland oregon hi gene welcome
to the dave ramsey show
hi hi dave um so
um i'm also calling because me and my
boyfriend have been together for two
years
and um my friend went to school for
eight years um but unfortunately with no
degree
he couldn't really make up his mind what
he wanted to do and
now he's 47 thousand dollars in student
loan debt
um his dad also took out uh
another 50 000 in a parent plus loan
uh so right now i mean my boyfriend
would love to buy a condo
but i'm just i'm not sure if or
whenever we're going to be able to do
that
he now works at a bank and he makes 33
000
a year i've gone from drop to job and
um i'm trying to figure out what i want
to do still
and if i go back to school though you
know i'm going to have to probably take
out
loans as well but i don't i just don't
want to do that you know i
have saved up seventeen thousand dollars
in my bank account right now right
mm-hmm but okay
let's stop a second okay are you guys
are you guys planning to get married
soon
um i mean okay no no you're not
okay so i mean i could just tell by the
way you started answering the question
so
if you're not planning to get married
soon you do not buy a house together
okay very very very dangerous
for you to own a house with your
roommate
because your roommate might up and leave
[Music]
i agree if your husband up and leaves
the court will make him pay for the
house
not your roommate and so
very unwise relationally uh
very unwise financially very unwise
legally
to buy a house with a guy you're
shacking up with it puts you
in a very vulnerable position and so
until you're married
quit looking at your lives through the
lens
of we because you're not a we yet
you're just you're just a dating couple
okay and you don't own you you legally
do not own anything together you legally
have not combined anything
and so you have to work on your career
path and your debts and he needs to work
on his career path and his debts
if you're getting married once you're
married then we'll talk about combining
these goals
and combining the ownership in the house
but
gene let me tell you here's what i've
run into for 30 years of doing what i do
the number of times stuff like this has
happened
a shacked-up couple buys a house
together they're partners
from a legal standpoint there is no
partnership agreement
because they were playing house acting
like they were married but they didn't
have the legal benefits of having been
married
he gets killed in a car wreck now you
own a house
with his mother because you're not the
heir
you have no legal standing in this
situation whatsoever
unless there's a will uh and
but if there's not then his heir would
be his parents
and so now you and his mommy are
partners in a house
this is a recipe for a life that sucks
yeah i agree and this is the kind of
thing that happens or he gets disabled
or something happens to you and he has
to deal with your mother
i don't know what it is or maybe it's
the father i don't know or maybe it's
the crazy brother which is the only heir
i don't know
but there's crazy and screwed up stuff
in every family and you get to play with
all of that as a partner
no thank you instead of as a thing so so
you need to take your 17 000
and decide what you're going to do with
your life and get about your business
of living your life that's right and
listen don't just fall to school as the
next thing to do
oh that's good i mean you you can't and
too many people have done that
and we've got young people that have
signed documents they don't understand
for payments they can't afford
so you start to think about what it is
you're going to do what it is you want
to do
as you work and i'm proud of you for
having some money set aside
be intentional and don't let that slide
through your fingers you do not need
student loans
no pick out a field of study and a place
to study
that is consistent with what you want to
do it's not a fallback it's not the next
thing to do that's right it's an
intentional series of actions that are
going to take you to successful living
you can no one wanders accidentally into
wealth
no one wanders accidentally into high
quality relationships
no one wanders accidentally into success
that's right they never interview the
guy at the end of the super bowl and go
how'd that happen and he goes oh no just
get off the bus
that's not what happens it's a series of
intentional
acts that cause people to win at things
yeah and so
gene what's missing out of all the
different parts of this
with your boyfriend and the parent plus
loans in the forty seven thousand
dollars in eight years in school
there's no intentionality he's wandering
around
chasing his tail you said i don't know
what i'm going to do
you guys really need to sit down and
start to think about individually and
or together right we're going to get
married it's going to be the life we
live we're going to
pursue these careers we're going to
pursue some things we're going to
set stand some things up and knock some
things down and uh but you're
you're not going to wander into
happiness it's not going to work you're
not going to wander into a level of
success a level of fulfillment
and for god's sakes don't buy a house
with somebody you're not married to